here's something for you I saw her
actually the other day brand is very
very interesting so a lot of people
think brand is that thing you invest in
that is a bit fluffy it's hard to track
and it's hard to measure however this is
why brand is really important so say if
you walked into Starbucks and there is
um two types of people in Starbucks sat
you know working at their laptops
there's somebody on like a Windows
laptop and there's somebody on a Mac if
you ask someone what do you think he's
working on on the Mac more than likely
say oh he's created a movie or something
like that what do you think he's working
on on them
boring here that's why brand is
important because what they do is
associate that person with a job for an
example it's an identity so you buy the
identity So when you buy a Macbook it's
because you want to be seen as a
creative you know the same with why you
buy Gucci or Chanel or whatever you want
to be associated with those words then
that's why brand is really important